hey guys welcome to another episode of
congratulations
crazy
[Music]
it's let's see what is it it is right
now december
and it is and we are in los angeles and
you know what that means
am i
hot or am i cold let's play am i hot or
am i cold yeah dude am i hot or am i
cold whoa it's my favorite most annoying
game show am i hot or am i cold now let
me tell you something dude we know if we
listen i'm just gonna start off i got
some [ __ ] stuff that i obviously i
want to talk about like we got looking
merch that's banging on all [ __ ]
syllables and all that [ __ ] and it's
just insane and you know i'm all about
the bags but i want to start
by playing this most annoying game show
of all time am i hot or am i not and
dude it's it's not about sexiness it's
about temperature you know if you listen
to this podcast and if you're an a
listener to this podcast that the host
of this podcast aka me is
you know i run i run cold i'm cold as
[ __ ] all the time i'm cold i keep my
hotel uh room [ __ ] at 78 degrees like
you're i'm practically a [ __ ] lizard
you know what i'm talking about now
kristen does she get mad
yes does the [ __ ] does does our nanny
get mad yes do people get mad when they
come over yes do i care no i pay the
bills it's all good calvin is he mad who
knows we don't know he barely talks he
barely talks and a lot of time honestly
we blow the uh the back of the air
conditioner that we have that one of
those tube ones that that that blows
really uh cold air into the podcast room
and we put the tube on the outside so it
ejects the hot air in the back i don't
know if you guys know these things a lot
of businesses have these
and uh and this is a business right we
run a business here so we have one of
those and the uh the the tube shoots out
and calvin goes and he sits down outside
of it and he looks at it and he goes hot
hot hot and he likes it so he might be
on team delaia well chris dalia right
because there's something to leave that
don't like it so
i run cold i always want the fireplace
on right i put it on at night and
kristen gets mad not only that it's hot
but also that it lights up the room like
the [ __ ] fourth of july and she can't
sleep because it's hot and bright
i
shimmer but i turn it off and i try to
sleep and she turns the air on and i'm
freezing like an icicle but whenever i
get that it's my deal
all right i get that it's my thing but
what i'm pissed off about
and i'm not mad
look i'm trying to get it
just i'm trying to be cool you know
obviously have an anger problem
um
just but don't we all you know what i'm
talking about people are always like
you know acting like
i told somebody i had an anger problem
they're like oh really oh wow that's
pretty that's pretty wild and i'm like
bro
you got one too okay
you're your person
you got an anger problem in this world
you don't have an anger problem in this
world honestly
what is
what is going on what is your iq
all right so
so i
am uh
now
it's december and that means in la
it's too
cold in the shade
but hot when you leave the shade
amazing dude amazing doesn't happen in
august doesn't happen in september it
happens a little bit in october and
november it'll be two weeks on two weeks
off and then december that's just what
it is
that's just what it is dude
honestly the first few days of december
it was
cold
i bought a sweater i left it in the car
i would go leave to go sit
nice at a cafe i'd be outside and i'd
just be in my t-shirt and i would be way
too [ __ ] cold
i'd have to go and get my i have to go
and get my
my [ __ ] sweater
dude isn't that amazing man and every
time every day i would do it i'd be like
i could probably do it this time and i'd
do it and it would be in the shade in
the cafe and then i have to leave and go
get it in my in my park car and i have
to do it in between the meal
[ __ ] yeah dude that's so cool why do i
do that
why my question is why do i do that i'll
like i'm the kind of guy that like holds
my piss for way too long until i'm just
extremely uncomfortable
dude i'll leave therapy and i'll be like
i'm thirsty uh i could ask my therapist
therapist for a couple a cup of water or
i'll just go home dude 10 minutes into
the drive i'm so parched and pissed off
that i gotta pull over
why do i do that
why do i why do i not prep i don't prep
for the actual
ride i don't prep for the day i don't i
don't do this [ __ ]
i don't know if i'm not bringing my my
my hoodie or my sweater to the place
out of just sheer [ __ ] like you remember
the whole depends thing where i got
depends because i'm like dude i'm not
gonna wake up to piss anymore that's my
body but i'm gonna use the depends to
[ __ ] win over my body i don't know if
you saw this episode but it was a few
episodes back
previously on congratulations so i did
it a few nights
and every night
i pissed all over the bed
like i started wearing depends to bed
because i'm like i'm not getting up
[ __ ] too early to take a piss i'm
gonna i'm gonna do and i would wake up
and i piss in the depends and i was
happy as [ __ ] i pissed all over the bed
because i was like body i win body like
my body was another person
it's all me but i'm like dude on my mind
and my body
do you understand
so i don't know why i do this but i
gotta talk actually i'm gonna talk to my
therapist about this because it seems
masochistic dude
i just i'm never the right temperature
is what i'm saying
i'm actually never the right temperature
cars
forget it forget it do cars even have
the right temperature
i'm either too cold dude if i put the
air on okay i'll put it on three minutes
gotta turn it off it's too cold so then
i [ __ ] i'm i'm in the car and then
i'm what i'm [ __ ] too hot and i got
my sweater on so i take my sweater off
i'm still too hot so i put the air on i
put the air on for three minutes i'm
[ __ ] too cold if i have a 20 minute
ride i'm [ __ ] changing outfits like
like i'm playing [ __ ] four parts in a
musical dude
it's unbelievable
figure it out cars figure it out whether
i got it that's why people live in
[ __ ] florida dude they always know
what they're gonna get
right
or even better like like a town that's
like the best town would be like not
like in a place
that
was just
like hawaii where you didn't even have
to really use cars that much you just
chilled on the beach and you know you
didn't even have like do they even like
the fact that places even have air
conditioning in on breezy beach you
don't need it dude you don't need it
you just need open walls and [ __ ]
and you just close the doors when it's
[ __ ] nighttime and it's beautiful man
it's beautiful although my mom did have
a beach house and dude when we would go
i'd be like it's touc
it's just so cold at the beach you know
[ __ ] man it it's never good you know
what dude i don't want to start off this
com podcast complaining let's let's talk
about something good i did i started off
complaining and i didn't even mean to i
wanted to talk about how happy i was i
wanted to talk about how happy i was
about [ __ ] uh
uh
merch and [ __ ] and just i didn't i
didn't but that's how we do it we fly by
the seat of our pants my babies that's
what we do but yeah we got the merch
we've got the world wide life rips
hoodies and pants and they just [ __ ]
fire no syllables we got to make friends
in the comments shits we got the [ __ ]
go medium and sometimes stay out we've
got all those sorts of pi you know and
it's awesome dude let me tell you
something too i see people out there
like reposting the merch purchases and
and out in the world wearing life rips
hoodies and [ __ ] and like just dude like
the support is just so cool man when i
see you on the street and you were in a
life rips hoodie dude
it's unreal to me man like your support
means the [ __ ] world you know and
even if you're just a listener and you
don't have that [ __ ] your support means
the [ __ ] world to me dude it really
does man
i just i [ __ ] love you for it man i
really love you for it and that's how i
meant to start the podcast but dude i
would never disrespect you and not talk
about how i feel i would never
disrespect you and [ __ ] come out here
with some planned [ __ ] if i didn't feel
like what like doing it and that's not
how i felt like doing it and now
this is how i i feel like saying it
right now so i respect you [ __ ]
to tell that to tell you like to tell it
like that um
yeah man
i was on stage the other day dude guess
get this dude i was on stage the other
day
get off stage guy comes up to me hey bud
and i never know if
it's going to be like some fans will
come up to you and talk to you like they
know you and those people have changed
the game for me they've changed the game
i don't know what i'm going to get now
it's social media that [ __ ] everything
up right i'm posting on social media the
rock posting on social media
kendall doesn't do it but like [ __ ]
you know the the third lead in [ __ ]
csi miami's posting on social media you
feel like you know these [ __ ]
basically you have everybody's number
because you could just dm them right
i mean wesley snipes i got his [ __ ] i
basically have his phone number i could
just dm him right now if i wanted to he
he'll get it i don't know if i'll check
it or not but who knows if he'll check
his phone
right
so basically i have a direct line
to kira sedgwick do you know what i'm
saying like i just do that's just how
social media is and so it makes everyone
seem like they know you especially
comedians because i have a podcast i
talk at least an hour every week
and people are riding their cars i know
you're riding in your cars right now and
you're like yeah yeah okay true yeah oh
that's right chris or no no chris i
don't agree with that but it feels like
we're having a conversation so you feel
like you know me so social media has
changed the game for celebrities it
really has now now people walk up and
they say yo what's up bro and they think
because they listened
that now i know you know i don't know so
i don't know if i know you or if you're
a fan is my point so a guy comes up he
says hey bud and i say oh what's going
on man don't know and he says dude i'm
so and so from
cameo and i go
that's the [ __ ] i know him i
know this guy right i met a lot of
people in my life i know this guy he's
from the app cameo and uh where i charge
fifty thousand dollars for a shout out
now i'm the most expensive person on
cameo by design that's how i want it to
be
i'm not doing it unless i get 50 racks
right
to shout out somebody on their bar
mitzvah or their birthday or their
bachelor party or whatever the [ __ ] it
is kwanzaa
uh hanukkah i can say honolulu
the most chilling ass jew and um
and so i
so i say oh yeah that's the dude from
cameo i met him before and he was like
what's up dude and i was like oh what's
up and uh we were talking and [ __ ] and
he was like um dude i know he's like
you should get on cameo he said just
take a look and i'm like i don't know
you know i made fun of it so [ __ ]
hard and i thought it was so funny but
you know me though also when bags are
involved all the [ __ ] goes out the
window you saw me do a burger king ad
you saw me do that for some racks i'm
not gonna not do it just because i don't
eat fast food if you want to [ __ ]
pass me some racks i'm for hire
so i'm like how much money do you think
i should i could really make on cameo
and he told me and my eyes go dollar
signs
so i
i am on cameo now
and if i don't make as much as that dude
said i was gonna make i'm gonna be so
[ __ ] mad so come through
yes dude i'm on cameo finally the wait
is over man i saw [ __ ] on it
dude like the guys from [ __ ] uh like
snoop dogg's on it and [ __ ] i saw the
guy from [ __ ] uh what's it called uh
shark tank is on it that guy dule from
that one show that's on that psych show
is that's funny as [ __ ] he's on i'm like
dude people i respect around the shits
i thought it was just for [ __ ] brian
callan and like the girl from real
housewives or some [ __ ] but rich
[ __ ] are on this [ __ ] so i'm
like dude give me rocks
[Music]
if i don't make what he said i am i'm
off cameo but i figured december's the
good month dude because december is
christmas and you can [ __ ] gift this
[ __ ]
pass me some [ __ ] racks dude pass me
racks i'm gonna take that money i'm
gonna dub i'm gonna keep doubling it
until they kill me that's what tupac
said dude except he said the n-word
can't
but yeah dude that's so [ __ ] ill man
collect the racks dude collect the
[ __ ] racks i put out a tick tock that
said why do [ __ ] oh it was from the
podcast the other day why do why do
people get so mad uh i i know i said why
do people uh why do construction workers
start early i thought it was a bit of
comedy put it on tick tock didn't
realize it was a ted talk everyone's
taking me to task saying well that's
what real americans do oh well [ __ ]
you little rich boy why the [ __ ] this
and that you don't know oh that's what
we can't do because we don't talk about
[ __ ] on funny things for an hour a
week okay dude fine whatever i guess i
give up guess i'll die like that meme
it's like what do you want from me i'm a
[ __ ] comedian
it's like walking up to a construction
worker after he built the house and say
well where are this is not a this is not
a building and they're going to say no
it's a house and i go [ __ ] that dude
it's just comedy that's what it's
supposed to be you're taking it
seriously that's like me calling your
house a building
now that's just a [ __ ] uh what do you
call them uh s not simile but [ __ ]
what do you call them
[Music]
comparison what do you call them
analogy now that's just an analogy for
that ass
you know
i took down my gabapentins because i
started forgetting [ __ ] words like
spider and i'm just like all right dude
i gotta i take three before bed i took
it down to two and last night i took one
because dude i i don't like having
restless restless leg syndrome and sure
gabapentins kind of help with that but
i'd rather remember the word spider than
have [ __ ] res than not have restless
leg syndrome i have a [ __ ] podcast
for christ's sake stayed up until four
four in the morning last night with
marissa's leg syndrome couldn't fall
asleep and then i [ __ ] gave up and i
and i [ __ ] busted i busted and then i
[ __ ] patched right out dude what's up
body
busting helps man and i want you to know
i'm not saying that to be [ __ ] weird
or creepy or silly but busting helps
that rls dude
[ __ ] that's like that one uh
youtube video these ribs really do be
busting you ever see that [ __ ] oh my god
dude have you seen it oh my god really
do be busting i gotta watch that right
now really
what the [ __ ] is it uh it's called what
are they eating
ah [ __ ] where is the youtube video here
we go
no that's the mcdonald's sprite one dude
i gotta find this [ __ ] can you find the
video ribs it's ribs right well i just
keep talking huh even if i don't if you
know if i don't i just [ __ ] don't
stop talking huh i get it now kristen
says sometimes i'm annoying i get it
right now is what i get it is it on
youtube wow i just keep talking dude
unbelievable i mean i don't even need to
be saying these things right now and i
just keep [ __ ] talking
would you found it or no
hear it here we go the oh the handshake
that's the handshake is what he does
hand shake is it ribs though that
they're eating i can't believe there
hasn't been one second that i haven't
been talking all right here what's the
handshake why can't i find it dude most
most like would it be most most liked
wow if you haven't turned off this
podcast by this point i don't get it i
sin seriously i i sin seriously that's a
new word
you know what i'm trying to say i don't
i don't get it but oh here you go
filters uh filters uh upload count view
count here we go up no there's nothing
in there did you find it why can't i
find it i'm pissed here we go it's in
this one
he needs some milk wow you know
here it is
man this [ __ ] busting bro
dude he sticks his finger in his mouth
wow he just [ __ ] violated the guys
man this [ __ ] be busting bro just a mess
with [ __ ]
barbecue sauce all over their face and
ranch on his face
man this should be busting bro
anyway busting helps rls is what i was
trying to say
uh and i want people to know because i
googled it does it really help and uh
there was only one article in
cosmopolitan in like 2012 about it and
i'm a doctor basically because i figured
out [ __ ]
busting helps rls and people have rls
out there they tell me about it they're
like oh dude i have rls and but you're
that's not that's no joke i really did
try busting and i'm just like all right
bro what am i [ __ ] who am i dr fauci
i'm basically dr fauci
anyway all i'm trying to say is i'm
trying to [ __ ] stack racks
trying to [ __ ] get past some racks
so um
oh what a dude my
i i called my dad on the last podcast at
the end of the last podcast i called my
dad to clear up some [ __ ] cause i
thought maybe he had dementia or
something you know dementia kind of runs
in our family and sometimes i feel like
getting it but then i like that i feel
like i have it but then i realized oh
[ __ ] it's probably just because i had
too many to get repentance
but um
my dad literally [ __ ]
dude we get to so he my dad says hey
show up to thanksgiving
3 30. or no he says oh can we do it at
two and i say hey dad you're forgetting
you've got a grandpa and what you're
forgetting you're a grandpa and what
that means is
you have a grandchild and what that
means is he naps and what that means is
you're not paying attention because his
bedtime is always
uh his nap time is always at two and
what that means is he sleeps till four
so what that means is we can't come as
two
because that's when his nap starts
so
let's do some thinking right
so he says well can you maybe come at 3
30. and so what that means is i now have
to have calvin go to sleep a little bit
earlier but what that means is it's a
holiday so it's all good and so what
that means is i just relax and i'm just
like okay we could do that if he doesn't
fall asleep he doesn't fall asleep he
could burn through a nap he's burned
through naps before and he's fine and i
i like to like you know
i'd like to like be good with my family
and like i'm trying to acquiesce do you
know what i mean so
so we wake up and we get over there we
make it by 3 30.
and in my dad's text he says we'll eat
at 3 30 and i say cool we get there at 3
nothing's ready it's okay it's okay
because nothing's ever on time i just
accept that nothing is ever ever nothing
is ever on time right people say yeah
i'll be there at 3 they show up at 305
and just that's how the world works okay
i'm in school remember in school when
they were like hey uh
you know if you're late you get [ __ ]
detention or demerits or whatever it is
or it affects your grade and this is
and this is uh
and this is to prep you in life because
when you're late for your job you get
fired and you're and then you grow up
and you're like [ __ ] no i don't dude
who people have been late for work for
like 30 minutes and people like don't do
it again dude it's fine if you're in
high school right now and you're late it
doesn't [ __ ] matter show up 15
minutes late what the [ __ ] are they
gonna do anyway that's just some secret
[ __ ] i'm telling you right now
um but
so i show up at 3 30 it's not ready it's
all good you know even i was probably
late i was probably 3 35 3 45 i might
even showed up at [ __ ] 350 and the
the turkey wasn't ready and that's okay
right
my dad
uh
it gets to be like 4 30
and i say
you know me and my brother like what the
[ __ ] you know we're starting to i can't
imagine what it sounded like to my dad
like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] talk
my mom [ __ ] what are you talking and
we say to mom say what's going on with
the food he said 3 30 right and she said
yeah he wanted you to be here by 3 30. i
said well he technically said he wanted
us to eat at 3 30 and i knew you're
going to say this so i checked earlier
to make sure that that was what he said
and he said he was going to eat at 3 30
and says yeah but you don't even want to
know what happened i said what the [ __ ]
happened
and she starts laughing
and i'm like what and she says
yeah he left the crock pot in the oven
and he preheated the crock pot and i was
like huh
and she said he
he keeps the crock pot in the oven for
storage
and he preheated the oven with the crock
pot in it
[Laughter]
and left it in there and [ __ ] just
went to watch tv he was like gotta
pre-heat the oven didn't realize he was
regular heat in the crock pot
went to go i and so i walked over to dad
and i was like dad and
what happened and he said guy [ __ ] i
didn't know i
i put the cr that i keep the crock pot
in the crock pot in the oven and i i
forgot i keep it in there and i started
the [ __ ] thing to preheat it and then
i realized it like you know 30 minutes
later i was like 30 minutes later how
did you realize this and he's
the whole house smelled like [ __ ]
plastic
and i was like really where were you and
he was like i was watching tv in the tea
room tv room is clear across the house
so that means that the [ __ ]
plastic on the crock pot went over like
smoke
tickling donald duck's nose while my dad
was watching [ __ ] combat or whatever
the [ __ ] show he that aired in 1948
that he's watching on [ __ ] the movie
channel or whatever the [ __ ] you know
and and it's just the croc plastic is
just doing this under his [ __ ] 73
year old nose and he gets up and it was
all melted
so he [ __ ]
took the yet that he had to wait for the
crock pot to cool down take it out and
now he can't use that oven they got two
ovens so now he's cooking everything in
the one oven
and so we end up eating at like five
and one of the people in the [ __ ]
thanksgiving had to leave so they didn't
even eat
and my dad was so [ __ ] mad dude and
when my dad's mad he just goes god damn
it like that's what he does dude he goes
god damn it so they left and they're
like here it is i hope it's good i don't
know if it's good i only had one oven i
planned for two ovens i only i left the
[ __ ] crock pot in the thing dude and
we [ __ ] ate it and everyone's like
wow this is amazing wow this is really
good he's like oh good i was worried and
let me tell you something dude it wasn't
that good okay and i'm coming clean with
you guys because i respect you all right
the turkey was dry now here's the other
thing turkey is kind of always dry
that's why you have the gravy that's why
you have the gravy i'm not even a gravy
guy but i use gravy on thanksgiving
because you because turkey is usually
dry it's really hard to cook turkey and
i know that because people tell me
people close to me tell me i don't know
that because i cook because i don't cook
because i [ __ ] hate cooking but i
trust some people and those people tell
me cooking turkey is very hard and
that's why you have the gravy all
right so i poured that gravy on there
and i still tasted dried turkey and i
drove home and on the way home i was
like hey dude now can we talk about it
the turkey wasn't good and people were
like oh i thought it was really good and
i was like are you [ __ ] actually
serious right now and they were like
yeah i was like you really telling me
that that turkey be busting and they
were like the turkey be busting and i
was like okay i guess i'm wrong dude i
guess i'm wrong
but dude the fact that my dad cooked the
crock pot for 30 minutes
and ruined the oven and asked to get
into a crock pot and ruin turkey
amazing with one click of the [ __ ]
wrist dude
[Music]
you guys know that holidays are the most
wonderful time of the year of course
they are but if you're running an online
store
you know they can also be the craziest
most stressful time of the year and i
know that because i run an online store
and i use shipstation it's a little
thing called ship station if you don't
know what it is you live under a rock
but let me tell you anyway uh you've got
inventory to manage okay orders to fill
and a growing list of stressed out
customers checking in twice a day
wondering whether those last minute
gifts will arrive in time well guess
what with ship station the hassle of
shipping out holiday orders melts away
leaving you with happier customers and
more freedom to run your business or
enjoy much needed time off
we are launching new merch all the time
you know that if you're listener of the
store and with shipstation everything
stays organized so we can get stuff out
fast just ask any of my fans who have
ever gotten any merch from me all right
they order it and sometimes even get it
the next day it's insane if you sell
anything online i don't need to tell you
that shipping can be super frustrating
uh there are so many carriers and a ton
of factors that go into figuring out the
best rate for each other uh with more
people shopping online every year it's
just getting bigger and bigger uh the
added holiday stress it doesn't help
ship station makes shipping the easy
part of running your online store is the
easy part so you can get back to doing
what you're passionate about growing
your business um ship station works with
all major carriers international and
local including fedex you usps and ups
and you get
uh even
access to discounted rates that are
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies it's just a great deal okay uh
it's no wonder 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business make this
holiday season a little brighter with
ship
uh use my offer code congrats to get a
60 day free trial just enough time to
handle the holiday rush just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter code congrats ship station make
ship happen
[Music]
yeah let me preheat it and i said to him
i was like dad don't you get
like when you put the crock pot in the
thing didn't you think like you have to
specifically think like i thought
okay chris your story like this is what
i would do if i was doing the thing if i
was gonna keep something in the oven i
would think okay chris
this is your time to remind yourself
right now that you're storing the crock
pot in the oven next time you preheat
the oven you must remember this and i
said didn't you think this and he's like
well i don't know yeah i guess and i'm
like no no dude no i'm talking about
specifically saying to yourself you
might even want to say it out loud okay
bill i'm putting the crock pot in this
[ __ ] oven
room and he's like i don't know you know
he didn't do that so he cooked the
[ __ ] crock pot
it's honestly irresponsible dude it's
also irresponsible to put the crock pot
in there knowing the next time that
you're gonna use the oven is probably on
thanksgiving like when did he put it in
there october dude that's too late
already
when you put that he probably put that
into november
right it's not like he's sitting there
not using the oven since it was february
okay but it wasn't
so now i'm like dude my dad's 73 between
that and just scooping last episode i
talked about how he just scooped up
pasta thinking it was his i'm like dude
is my dad gonna die in [ __ ] two years
does he have just dementia but it turns
out dude
you know what he is a just a regular dad
that's what he is
he's just a regular dad
like i am
dude so i'm i'm such a dad right now
that i i i've officially
i have officially crossed the point to
where not only do i know if a viral
video is fake or not
but i don't care
do you understand people be like dude
that's fake bro they got you and i go
ah it's still funny
that's how much of a dad i am
that's how much like when people try
people i was married once before uh when
i was 26 and people ask me uh how's
marriage and here's the definition of
marriage here's the definition of being
married okay
when your wife
decorates the apartment
not how you want
and you realize you don't not want that
you don't care
you don't care people know oh man she
got to decorate it all like like they
come over my [ __ ] apartment they'd be
like dude what's this [ __ ] when she
my ex-wife hung a window on a on a wall
like a [ __ ] put a framed window on a
wall like it was like art
and people guys would come over there
like what the [ __ ] is this a window on a
wall and it's baby like are you [ __ ]
you're married and you [ __ ] she's got
you putting windows on walls is that you
can't even open it that's just on a wall
and i would be like dude you can't
imagine the level i don't care
she could put a window in the bed i
don't give a [ __ ]
that's what it's like being married and
this is what it's like being a dad
these viral videos they got me
and i don't care
[ __ ] are out there pretending
to saw their nuts off and i'm going oh
that looks like it hurts
and they're like haha they got you they
still got nuts and i go oh man looks
crazy
i just don't care
i'm dad mark 10. dude
my son says no dada it's cute as [ __ ] no
dada i go to hug him he says no dada
he's already got a personality i'm
[ __ ]
i'm like dude i just want a hug i want
to kiss your cheek dude you're my son i
made you know that already i'm like
already you're this person
for [ __ ] sake dude no dada and now i
got to be like well [ __ ] man that [ __ ]
carries with you okay i gotta let the
kid do what he wants to to a point right
you know what i'm so you know what i'm
saying
so
you can't just be [ __ ] kissing all on
your kid's face and [ __ ]
not if he's saying no dada so
i don't know man but you also got to
find the balance like you wanted to play
with [ __ ] mommy's id
you want to play with mommy's id and
he's running around the house with
mommy's id and i'm like you got it you
can't do it you're going to lose it and
he doesn't know so i take the id and i
put it back on the island and he's just
like
he's talking to the id and i'm like
buddy you can't have it you're going to
lose it you don't have the capacity yet
to understand that you're going to lose
this and mom's not going to be able to
drive and i'm saying all this [ __ ] to a
one and a half year old and he's just
like no dada no dad i'm like i can't win
what am i doing
is this how he's learning to talk or
already arguing
and he's just straight up winning with
[ __ ] not even with two words and one
of the words repeats it's dad that's not
even fair
he's saying two syllables and absolutely
icing the [ __ ] out of me
it's crazy when you realize your full
dad
it's crazy
um
you know but i'm full dad and it's all
good and that's not the name of this
episode by the way i know what
everybody's thinking
um
dude well virgil abloh died and that's
sad who knew man
these guys get cancer they don't tell
anyone you know uh nor mcdonald nobody
he didn't tell anyone
virgil abloh didn't tell anyone and
[ __ ] chadwick boseman didn't tell
anyone they just up and died and they
had a whole struggle and nobody knew
about
it made me think like what if i got
cancer would i tell people bro i will be
the loudest person
i would come out of the doctor excited
to tell people i would wait to feel all
of the sadness and i would run out of
the doctor and i'd be like guess what
world
i've got two and a half years left
it's gonna be on and [ __ ] popping
until i gotta lay in a gurney dude it is
gonna be so unpoppin you get to know
look in this past year and a half you
got to know how i really feel
if i get
diagnosed dude
if your boy
is staring at a guy
through a pair of his glasses and a
white coat
getting diagnosed
[Applause]
grabbing [ __ ] with my talent
[Music]
dude with the feet up dude like eagles
like eagles do like the [ __ ]
dangerous ones the eagles that show
their [ __ ] you know what i'm talking
about they're [ __ ] and [ __ ] when
they're trying to get the [ __ ] trout
that's me dude
if a doctor sits there and diagnoses me
with some [ __ ] rare [ __ ]
duck
this is you this is everybody around me
if your boy gets diagnosed
for real dude
i'm serious business dude i come out
on this podcast turns into
[ __ ] you know what it turns
into for real
[Music]
that's what it turns into dude
the doctor says
mr dalia sit down yes you have a rare
form of heart cancer and i just stand up
[Music]
grab him by the lapel and i'm out dude
but it's sad dude you know we lost a
good one we lost
i loved his [ __ ]
i thought off-white was one of the
better was one of the best brands
because
honestly
some of this [ __ ] was this is the best
stuff in life some of this stuff is
awesome and some of the stuff i'm just
like
who the [ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna wear
that
right like the fact that you know virgil
abloh was a good designer i mean many
reasons
but the reason why you know he was a
good designer is because what one of
those [ __ ] uh
quavo or quavo whatever the [ __ ] wore to
his [ __ ] thing
the guy had a purple top hat on i don't
know which one he is of the [ __ ]
group what's that group called
migos the three amigos
one of them were a purple top hat and a
[ __ ] like pilgrim outfit and i'm just
like god damn it the fact that virgil
abloh
was able
to make this guy wear this
at his [ __ ] just without even saying
to do it with just him through creating
the fact that this
dude from migos showed up
in that absolutely
you know that gay pilgrim outfit that
[ __ ] mad hatter
it's just so
awesome that that's his that's part of
his legacy made
whoever that migo was the worst dressed
person i've ever seen in my life you
know what i'm talking about
like kid cudi wore a green [ __ ] neon all
neon dude people dressed like such
[ __ ] at his [ __ ] thing that even
like
people from alice in wonderland would be
[ __ ] let's throw the other
like dude they just dressed with big sun
one guy was blindfolded just feeling his
way around
like dude what what the [ __ ] a guy
showed up in a tux
to the back and just walk backward like
what are these guys doing
one guy sawed his [ __ ] legs off at
the knees and just said this is what
fashion is now
it's just like
virgil abloh had an effect on
[ __ ]
and that's cool right 41. that [ __ ] me
up man that [ __ ] me up when i heard he
died you know i didn't know him at all
but like
um
yeah [ __ ] me up man because uh
i'm 41 dude and i you know i don't mean
to make it about me but
it [ __ ] made me s weird all day dude
just texting my brother and [ __ ] and
just like
it's just weird somebody can be taken
from you from in a moment dude and i
didn't know he had kids
i didn't know he had a wife and kids man
you know it's it's it's it's odd that
even a fashion designer would have a
wife and kids because they're you just
assume they're gay i guess that's
prejudice but like
man
you know
[ __ ]
nor mcdonald him and the [ __ ]
chadwick boseman you know it's just like
[ __ ] i had a buddy die two weeks ago i
didn't talk about on the podcast but
it's just like
uh
it was rough man
anyway
hmm i feel like these podcasts just get
[ __ ] sadder and sadder
they don't though dude
the life
dude life is pain life is beautiful and
life is pain
i feel you do it if you're going through
a hard time if you lost a loved one i i
[ __ ] i want to be there for you
i do
i really really want to be there for you
um but i got my own [ __ ] i'm dealing
with you know like kristen is like
decorating for christmas even still
she's not done yet
i'm joking well i'm joking that i'm
saying that i'm not joking that she's
not done dude our christmas tree on the
upstairs dude i put out a video on with
chris
decorating uh unboxing decorations and
we did the tree and that's just one of
the trees dude we have more trees it's
like dude
there's a tree upstairs and it's so big
and beautiful and she [ __ ] killed it
dude i didn't actually look at it until
yesterday and i stepped back and i
looked at it and i was like jesus christ
this is gorgeous and she was so happy
that i said that
and i was happy too and it's nice dude
she's like isn't it nice when you and
i'm like yeah she's like do you think i
do too much of it and i'm like of course
but you know what i mean it's like all
good if it's what makes you happy
decorate the whole [ __ ] thing dude
put everything everywhere if it makes
you happy wrap the house in [ __ ] wall
uh wrapping paper i don't rap calvin who
cares
wrap him the bed every night
just waking up with [ __ ] tear
wrapping paper
opening himself waking up every morning
dude it's just like
it makes her so happy
it's so cool to have that people have
that people don't have hobbies you know
the fact that she has that hobby
um so yeah so we put out [ __ ] uh with
uh the that on the with chris video and
then we put a um
another one on the with chris video uh
uh the macrib one and then i put out the
making the pie with calvin on the mcrib
one all right not to make room i'm with
chris one jesus christ got opinions and
um
so yeah
uh
what was i saying about that i don't
even remember but dude the tree looks
[ __ ] goddamn like rockefeller i'll
take i'll have hers take a picture and
put it on her instagram [ __ ] [ __ ] that
so she was like let's do another one for
video chris i'm like dude i'm what am i
a christmas guy was my whole brand
changing
so i had to [ __ ] shoot guns with
brian callan on my last with with chris
uh we went to that taran uh
taran tactical place um
i'll talk about it more next time
because we actually didn't do it yet but
i'm saying we did it because this will
come out after we release it anyway
that's a little [ __ ]
how you make the sauce here on the
[ __ ] congratulations podcast i'm
showing you the sauce
but anyway dude that's that let's do
some misconnections
it's everybody's favorite segment miss
connections
um oh good and this good thing i always
do it at the end when my contacts are
blurry yes love when my contacts are
blurry dude here we go
i mean
this one's called foul move
and it's in parentheses palms [ __ ] my
contacts are blurry as [ __ ]
um it says
tap the photo twice
i got it right here do it and i can zoom
in
and zoom in and zoom in like the guy
from [ __ ] what's his name from cnn
and you zoom in and you zoom into the
county
um
foul move palms good luck in new york
mind the cold
r
uh hey guy
what is this your diary
what the [ __ ] did this guy mean to send
a text message
i mean who's checking this for this this
guy's using it as a [ __ ] texting app
wow
here's another one
wow okay uh you used to tutor me oh
this'll be good irvine dude i used to
[ __ ] man when i was two i hated getting
tutored when i was a kid i hated getting
tutored when i was a kid
i had a really good looking tutor too
she was really [ __ ] beautiful
and um so let's see where this goes
uh used to you used to tutor me irvine
you were an older woman well no [ __ ] you
know
if she tutored you she was older i lost
your contact i wonder if it was my tutor
looky did i write this looking for you
or someone that can tutor me i mean dude
you know
gave up two sentences in
just like to be taught really it gives
me boners
looking
dude how does he
you were an older woman i lost your
contact looking for you or someone that
can tutor me hoping to find my lost
tutor hey guy stop saying tutor
would be the worst [ __ ]
you know sometimes you send a text and
you realize you said a word too many
times you got to go delete it and
[ __ ] either not use it or use a
different word
i [ __ ] i had a text like that where i
was saying it too many times
a word too many times and i i went to go
i was like i gotta delete this i sound
like a [ __ ] lunatic that doesn't know
any words and i said [ __ ] it and i just
sent it that's the kind of real [ __ ]
that you get from me dude if you're a
text friend with friend with me that's
the kind of real [ __ ] that you get from
[ __ ] daddy i'll tell you that much
all right dude here's another one i
don't fix my text not sometimes i send a
text out and then i [ __ ] i know it's
wrong and i send it wrong knowing it's
wrong and then i send a follow-up text
not fixing it and i have it shortcut it
in my phone n f i for not fixing it and
i just hit the spacebar it says not
fixing it i send that too and that's the
kind of [ __ ] i am dude and
that's the
disrespectful respect i showed to my
friends if we're text friends
i'm a real person
here's another one
want to help oh
sid double entendre
well i love the [ __ ] first line of
the body on this one the the title is
want to help with your wood
as if that's not good enough he starts
out
saying
quite simple
that's the first line of the body
first of all was already simple
if you don't get that double entendre
your iq
is 40.
okay
he says after that looking for someone i
could take care of your would
now i know why you said quite simple
because you thought smart people
wouldn't get it
because you're dumb
and we know that now because of the
sentence that you wrote that reads
looking for someone i could take care of
your wood
so [ __ ] foreign
that's like the guy at the gas station
that would ask you if you want [ __ ]
you're looking for someone i could take
care of your wood
mail for mail send pick for reply do not
contact me on solicited services or
offers
wow these are [ __ ] banging right now
here's another one dude
taco what
taco
is that what it says my contacts are so
[ __ ] blurry
taco nazzo la habra california
we used to
what used to be at this location before
taco not
hey man google it
hey man this is miss connections google
it
what connection are you missing
google.com
meet up with it in your browser
just right in your browser while you're
writing it now on craigslist miss
connections
hey guy
be less sad
oh and then it says it's okay to contact
this poster with services or other
commercial interests like a guy would be
oh dude i actually have no idea about
the taco nazzo thing but want me to take
care of your wood
quite simple let me take dude quite
simple don't know the wood guy hits him
up quite simple i have no idea about the
taco naza thing but want me to take care
of your wood quite simple
here we go ooh this is a good one just
simply the title is
pantyhose
and it was in irvine
why women are baron wearing wow why
women abandon wearing wow is this eminem
why women abandoned whammy
why women abandon wearing nylon
pantyhose and stockings what else can be
sexier than women's legs and pantyhose
just a thought
oh it's so lonely
hey guy
go outside more
hey guy go find the table on an outdoor
patio somewhere and just sit down for an
hour your whole life will turn around
this guy's on miss connections dude just
asking a question
like he's talking to one of his bros
hey even though it says do not contact
this dude with unsolicited services or
offers
do them a favor
contact them with something unsolicited
needs friends
unbelievable dude here's another one
beige gym pants costa mesa
it's the man in black i want to smell
your hair i am ready to give you all my
money it's creepy
just for smelling hair
nice
beige gym pants
oh that's like when chicks wear beige
pants at the gym and for a second you're
like
did she show up naked like that's how
idiots guys are that's how much of an
idiot we are
hold up
did she just wear a turquoise shirt and
that's it with [ __ ] nikes on
oh wow here's a long one
we'll go out with this one
whole foods redondo beach no bra nice
smile thanks
wow really just no punctuation
just cut into the chase with too many
it's hard to cut to the chase with that
many words but he did it
whole foods redondo beach no bra nice
smile thanks redondo beach huh
cut to the chase
alas with too many words
first subject of the body is whole foods
redondo beach
it says i was at whole foods pch me old
51 years
six
foot
bald jeans gray hoodie
averaging looks hey guy
i like that you're being real but have a
little bit of
confidence cross paths a few times with
pretty tallish female does that mean
she's pretty and tall or pretty tall
well he is a bad he's he's bad at
writing so
could be either dress with thin white
top showing off no bra look that's the
[ __ ] hilarious thing is like this
dude thinks that this girl was showing
off and this girl was probably just
throwing on a top to go to [ __ ] whole
foods and get some goddamn cauliflower
i'll tell you what she didn't want
[ __ ] eggplants
wish this was on standby because it
would have been good oh yes
that's the guy thinking she wanted
eggplants
wow that [ __ ] absolutely kills me
that thing the way he [ __ ] laughs so
heartily
um
each time nice smile he says like
doesn't even [ __ ] use articles in
this the or uh each time nice smile and
i think she knew i enjoyed who are you
talking to her or people is this a poem
and each and i think she knew i enjoyed
the view even if this woman is
reading this thinking oh maybe this is
me she starts reading and she gets
wrapped up in the story at this point oh
okay who's this woman oh this guy wow
oh and then the last the one is
nice bouncy
ah
dude he just says hey dude imagine
walking up to a chick and just saying
my god i i'm sorry but i just have to
compliment your bouncy
have a nice day
nice bouncy have a nice day i love the
way you're showing off with that note
with that with the no bra look
uh then it says in cap which is the only
thing caps thanks
wish that would happen to us oh me wow
i'm really blurry here wish that would
happen to me more often
sad
like this woman like this woman with by
the way a really nice bouncy is going to
just [ __ ] go back and [ __ ]
you know what i mean let them
meet my lemon you know she's reading
this let me meet you halfway i got a
nice bouncy i know it let me show off
with the no bra lock and co and just
chill at the whole foods and see if this
bald average looking guy comes along
oh and here we go any others wish to
show off to me i wish
so sad to say i wish on craigslist
that's
unbelievably sad i wish
you need to hang out with your buddies
and you say like oh god
one time we [ __ ] i was at a sleepover
when i was a kid with a bunch of other
kids and i remember i felt so i still
think about this dude
i was like man i was i was young and
like i wasn't like the hot guy
yet
your boy [ __ ] started dripping with
charisma and used it to up his sexy
levels
but
at this point i had just moved from new
jersey
and i was really dorky and i had a step
haircut and i looked like a q-tip that
had no bottom
we all slept on the trampoline at a
sleepover at my friend's house
and they were talking about chris why
don't you get a chick you know you don't
get a chick and i said he's like why
don't you go for her and i thought she
was cute
and i said
and i didn't even mean to sound like
this but i said why would a girl like
that be and be interested in a guy like
me and i was like hold up dude what am i
in a [ __ ] what is this foot like what
[ __ ] after school special i didn't
mean to say it like that and then i felt
the [ __ ]
trampoline bouncing like the guys were
sitting up like what the [ __ ] you say i
was like no i don't know i didn't really
mean it like that but i always think
about that and that's
the only thing sadder than this guy
saying
i wish at the end of his [ __ ]
misconnection
a lot of these guys need to be contacted
with unsolicited services and offers but
anyway that's the episode of
congratulations we really appreciate you
uh thanks for listening uh we love if
you're on the patreon and if you're not
we love that you're on youtube remember
to make friends in those comments and
dude don't go so hard maybe sometimes go
medium and stay out but make sure to
make friends in those comments now below
you see people being nice friend up with
them you see people talking [ __ ] they
need them more and just say would you
like to go to arby's or i've got fresh
[ __ ] meats won't you come on over i
live in akron ohio
really appreciate you going over to
chrisley.com get that merch the life
ribs mug is in full effect on the
worldwide light worldwide life
[ __ ] it just go to crystallia.com all
right guys that's it for the episode uh
on youtube if you want go catch the
unedited uh i'm peppeted
hey guys that's it for the youtube
hey guys that's it for the episode on
youtube if you want to check out the
rest of the episode the uncut
unfiltered i mean this wasn't unfilled
[ __ ] goddamn it hey guys that's the
end of the episode on youtube but if you
want to catch the rest of the episode
the uncut episode on patreon going over
to patreon.com crystalia it is longer no
ads no commercials uncut uh going over
and it's just for six bucks and we have
an episode
extra on the patreon uh once a month
we've got like 10 episodes now if you
sign up today you get access to those
episodes right now and we also do a
segment called review mode that is an
extra it's content just extra content
all day long six bucks you get all that
uh
patreon.comcrystalia go on over thanks
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
god i'm so blurry right now